The 1970s gave us the perfect laboratory for studying human fragility, not in the wild, but in cages.
Captive pandas, you see.
They were living in paradise, or at least what we call paradise.
Bamboo pre-cut and delivered, temperatures locked in like a bank lulled, no predators, no surprises.
By every measure, they were thriving.
And yet, they couldn't breed.
They couldn't even handle a slightly wilted stalk of bamboo.
They had become what we now call comfort-fragile so delicate that the very conditions meant to protect them had hollowed them out.
We call this the zoo-panda paradox.
Now, if you've ever read Nassim Taleb, you know his obsession with anti-fragility.
The idea that what doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
A bone bends under pressure and grows denser.
A muscle tears and rebuilds itself tougher.
A mind forced to adapt becomes unbreakable.
But misery?
Misery isn't built on strength.
It's built on the exact opposite.
To perfect your suffering, you don't seek chaos.
You seek sterility.
You don't want challenges.
You want nothing at all.
And modern life?
It's designed to give you exactly that.
What?
The Architecture of Fritzenless Living
We've spent centuries inventing ways to erase discomfort.
Delivery apps so you never have to walk.
Algorithms so you never have to choose.
Climate control so you never have to adjust.
We've turned the world into a smooth, polished surface-no-edges.
No surprises.
No reason to adapt.
And what happens when you remove all friction?
You don't get safety.
You get brittleness.
Consider the miserable individual.
To them, the world isn't just inconvenient.
It's hostile.
A neighbor's vacuum cleaner isn't background noise.
It's a personal assault.
A delayed train isn't a minor delay.
It's a betrayal.
They haven't just removed stressors.
They've removed everything that makes life worth enduring.
And the worst part?
They don't even realize they're broken.
They think they're being smart.
Huh.
Instructions for Psychological Fragility
If you want to cultivate true misery,
you need Comfort Guardrails rules
to keep you from ever having to face the world on its own terms.
First, there's the Silicon Shield.
Never leave your house without a pre-mapped route,
a pre-ordered coffee,
a schedule so rigid that even a wrong turn feels like a crime.
Serendipity isn't just inconvenient.
It's dangerous.
Dangerous!
A random encounter?
That's your brain practicing resilience.
A wrong turn?
That's adaptation in action.
Eliminate both, and soon,
the idea of choosing anything will feel like torture.
Then comes the 72-degree doctrine.
Your body was built to handle change-cold mornings,
warm afternoons,
the occasional draft.
But you?
You demand perfection.
73 degrees?
Unbearable.
71?
You'll freeze.
You've trained yourself to see minor discomfort as a crisis.
A slightly chilly room isn't just annoying.
It's a violation.
And when the real cold comes,
you'll shatter.
Next,
the filter bubble of affirmation.
Your mind should only feed on what confirms your worst fears.
Dissenting opinions?
Too risky.
Challenging ideas?
Outright dangerous.
You've built a mental fortress where only your irritations are allowed.
And when,
when,
something slips through,
your entire world view will crack like glass.
Finally,
the safetyism fallacy.
You don't want agency.
You want protection.
The job with the best dental plan,
but no challenges.
The hobby with no risk,
no failure,
no growth.
You're not building a life.
You're building a padded cell.
And the best part?
You'll never even notice the walls.
The Talibian inversion.
Talib would have you believe that chaos makes you stronger.
That volatility is your friend.
But you?
You're the inverse Talib.
You're the person who doesn't just hate minor discomfort.
You're destroyed by it.
A delayed flight isn't an inconvenience.
It's a decade lost.
A slightly burnt toast isn't carelessness.
It's an existential threat.
Mastery of misery isn't about enduring great pain.
It's about becoming the kind of person for whom nothing is tolerable.
Not the cold.
Not the noise.
Not the uncertainty.
You've trained yourself to see the world as a series of threats.
And soon,
even breathing will feel like work.
And the irony?
You'll never know you're the problem.
Because in a world that's done everything to remove friction,
you've become the only thing left that can't handle it.
He who seeks the frictionless life shall find that the smallest grain of sand
becomes a boulder.
And you?
You're the boulder waiting.